bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
nessuno video sono parigi oggi inizia un
altro video interessantissima e molto
molto molto intelligente beckett
aspettare esiste un mondo parallelo dove
io sono youtuber e faccio giochi tipo ba
lorant tipo counter strike tipo
overwatch league of legends e sono il
campione del mondo di tutti e quattro in
universo parallelo succede questa cosa
qui no vediamo che cacchio uscito fuori
allora la t bird alla fine noi normale
marino vediamo vediamo
viviamo di caoch è perfetto
devo fare devo fare un punteggio decente
giacche sono con la mia testa ho perso
maledetta marta che hai fatto 538
riproviamo meno male che è cambiata la
faccia signori se non sarebbe stato un
problema 122 non è male la suspense che
hai avuto giocando a fra pj non è nulla
in confronto a quella che provai
leggendo il mio libro anche gli sponsor
nel gioco è certo
poiché i flavi con la tua faccia premi
per regalarlo prima perfetto c'è miglior
cielo già però grazie a riprova vediamo
meno ma è con le cuffie ciò più hitbox
quindi intelligenti e più difficile per
gusti attenzione attenzione 12 è
veramente difficile ragazzi è più
difficile floppy per normale perché di
schiacciare molte più volte c'è floppy
board normali in confronto alla cazzata
ma che figo l'api bird normali confronto
una cagata perché qua devi schiacciare
veramente un sacco di volte jamie giuro
ma basta mettereste facce le carte cesso
quater hanno messe spiegatemi domanda
[ __ ] col demonio
niente proprio è difficilissimo ok
record record perfetto non farò mai più
di così allora allora restano solo io
questo il mio cane ma porco il demonio
mi spiegate come è possibile che anche
giocando con summerlab la sconfitta è
proprio necessaria
che mio zio non posso battere le corne
anche col mio cane che poi altro non
sammy bird questo non ha veramente senso
devo fare meglio almeno almeno sei
almeno sei perché veramente vi giuro
la free bird in confronto non è niente
no sto scherzando porca ma veramente
addio si 66 come di solito faccio non
posso risultare i cantori di questo
gioco perché me l'hanno mandato loro
quindi porca vacca
una versione che mi vista in di nervi
visto gioco forse esiste vediamo ecco
finalmente questo questo e questo è
fattibile questo almeno sette le faccio
neanche quello
ma attenzione abbiamo ancora questo
invece un downgrade non scherza anche
flat i disagi non sono anche parte di
voi pensate che c'era solo per il buon
famiglie ma non c'è solo primo un colino
e comunque no è difficilissimo non si
può fare però figo mi è piaciuto non sei
ragazzi se ve lo ricordate ma già che ci
siamo un replay potrebbe essere
interessante zuppa creations state
cercando un gioco che sia fantastico
istruttivo realistico e con una grafica
mozzafiato perfetto ragazzi questo gioco
non fa per voi
[Musica]
mamma mia
the films ritmi laica fucking sua allora
giochiamo
questo era un gioco che era uscito nel
2015 14 15 quindi stiamo parlando di
secoli fa aveva fatto questo ragazzo
signor poi j the game il gioco più bello
della storia
starring fi gay come questa epicità può
essere scomparsa nel tempo non è mai
scomparsa ieri nei nostri cuori e peep e
pip sarebbe un cattivo di penombra
quindi si parte che sia questo villa
gino molto carino
in fondo a questo villa gino vive un
personaggio che tutti noi conosciamo e
stimiamo e amiamo chiamare ovviamente
dove la nutella
ok va bene che mario mi ha rubato la
nutella devo fare felice 2014 per i
ragazzi set mario fermato la nutella
non sarà che dove sia finito al sogno
cercare tutti dove erano della madonna
mi verrebbe un infarto dopo un secondo
di tutto sto casino dove devo entrare il
turno ma arriva un camion four non mi
ricordo niente ragazze sincero però poi
ci scommetto lariana macchina non arriva
non arriva niente
perfetto stava scherzando arrivai mi
sembrava strano
ok si è sfasciata la macchina già questo
è un buon segno c'è questa era la fine
però finito così mi prendete per il culo
ma che cazzo di senso vera sto gioco
basta la sigla di jesus christ superstar
allo ragazzi tutto sto casino o
semplicemente notato che una volta io
non riesco neanche più a fare il fa vj
di una volta ora che ci vengono e
scopriamo urlare così tanto che potevo
fare non riesco neanche impegnandomi
difficilissimo c'è tipo questi ragazzi
c'era questo è è finito così ma che
cazzo vuol dire se non mi devi impegnare
tantissimo ed è difficile non riuscirei
mai un impegno abnorme vabbè tutto
questo la sigaretta o cerca di cantare
per coprirsi lei giudica del tutto presa
per non farmi mettere copyright cosa in
questo video non succederà aiuto sono
vivo perché la fisica non esiste
ma di cosa parliamo ma di cosa ok questo
e perdona l'esploratrice ma chi produce
avevo
[Musica]
porca vacca come del check in e vai
mario eccolo sopreso anno non ti posso
prendere cos'è sta roba toilette è tutto
questo che mario dove c'è un
c'è un passaggio di giampiero metti una
canzone che non è più legata molto bene
questa va benissimo allora vediamo se
tipo solo va ma che il mais suppor quali
droghe prendi assume mi spero tu abbia
smesso bucket mare in tutto sto casino
questa roba
e ve lo chiedo anch'io e che mario che
sta scappando qua la micela
all.ri single
viene dato space invaders va al ros
vabbè vite 5 aiuto cosa devo fare
cosa avevo devo schivare cosa c'è un
nayan cat che boal madonna rega cosa
succede
volendo egregio signor lori la
informiamo che a causa di un taglio di
budget siamo costretti ad abbassare la
qualità del ecco i provini per star trek
avere bellissimo palermo è bello anche
così è caro di budget del gioco ragazzi
ma va benissimo dove lo stesso mettendo
due ore anche a due ore aiuto o due vite
solo questo è veramente difficile
ok ok ne manca uno è morto perfetto e lo
fa o dio che mai è stravolta non mi far
iniziare tutto di far in italia no
colpiscono colpisco aiaf ci siamo
ragazzi stavolta ce la faccio stavolta è
fatta è fatta anche se non ho ben capito
come dovrei colpirlo visto che ci mette
un'ora sanità proprio lui è quindi
adesso esplode il mondo di co star trek
questo vale lo sappiamo
è un finale alternativo di star trek
questo ma no sono ancora di fatta una
cosa violenta non esploso il mondo va
bene aiuto si genera dell'erba di tutto
questo che mario ancora non l'ho trovato
che è battaglia di poker fa vj incontra
pif selvatico missile nucleare spacca
culi deretano di fuoco per gli usa
dell'eterno di fuoco non è molto
efficace spaccano colmi se nucleare
spacca cui perfetto fire ice 20 punti
expo che non serviranno a niente per il
resto del gioco certo a questo percorso
di ripresa in un gioco così spiega mi
madonna che i ricordi bellissimi
entra nella nebbia che chi è dark souls
alla nutella un miraggio tutela
questa non è la nutella 9 cat e bones 30
su 30 oddio para eccolo madonna che
palla poi non mi ricordo più quel punto
ha così ok mi chiama e difficilissima st
parte se non ti ricordi come devi
saltare porca vacca e res cam o sparami
fratello 6 formaggio
proprio lui alla fine del mondo dovuto
esplodere
ok le stava in cina tra l'altro perché è
così parigi e riuscì a recuperare la sua
amata cambia canzoni sottofondo e queste
coprire data nutella torno alla nutella
torno a casa a cavallo di un magico pony
arcobaleno fine
beh è una trama migliore di twilight
questo è il quality contenti che abbiamo
tutti bisogno sia piaciuto presta era un
tuffo nel passato anche nel presente
perché proprio per della presente ma
fatemi sapere se volete altri su altri
giochi che hanno fatto per me che non ce
ne sono ma ne faranno ne sono sicuro noi
ci rivediamo come sempre dal prossimo
video bella ragazza
[Musica]
ma